[Music]
what's up everyone Persia here from
GameSpot and today I am joined by the
executive producer on Tiffin martyt
Poussin and tsujimoto sign so Stefan was
announced and it looks amazing
what were the biggest challenges of
creating a brand new card game
so it must feel like a weight off of
your shoulders but what's interesting is
that it's a card game that isn't
completely turn-based what was the
inspiration behind that has amazed me
you don't know how much you see a sniper
to except attack ie cup ID other time is
not a Cinco stay good Tito : 'eat I stay
so cool I'm not a vacuuming up re-upped
a so on game said to know Iman invited
to talk about the up okay you don't
surrender Deacon that I got on Sailor
Moon are the killings and I got Tito
Colorado they must only are tagged no
battery today
that's awesome awesome so we're
definitely looking forward to it and
with the competitive aspect in mind
there are a lot of different aspects of
the game that I think traditional card
game players might have to think about
differently is there anything in
particular in terms of game plan that
you think someone who's played other
card games would have to change going
into this one
the other time you say to some tongue
say to you know mix toss toss toss toss
diva so no gave me you know game yeah
dono game timo jutila gave me nothing
today but even someone like I would give
up my joie de cristal ha ha my own area
single canonical variables
determination okay a tequila student
optimal zone kohaku museo de la Sabatino
John Doe no game freya kara itoshii
genre go stay on the moral Ebola Thomas
I'm really excited to see how the
competitive scene turns out because
there's so many different aspects of the
game you know we have the active
response but we also have the hero art
activation which is like the Power Move
is that gonna be the comeback mechanic
for the game soon a machine or does it
anymore
nah she's gonna come out you know acting
wooden spoons just come out games Dino
mechanics in like a little : ok da da di
da Matta venado concept so it will make
even that a hero at whakatane so my hero
not a variation of photo not even though
Maharaja Maharaja
McRaven the eldest daughter Attica
Alchemist in Laguna Napolitano aqui na
ma patty Jack tenemos que Rubio Marcy a
Casey you know he's young you called a
hero at the stake
ya know when it comes to the game itself
and all of its mechanics what is your
personal favorite mechanic of the game
you don't know same pony oh they talked
about you she gave me I didn't know
socata clue no de una zona
I know CIA team Oh señor Quixote gave me
no cortical appeared over Moscow MC
token I thought my deck building is
always a huge aspect of any card game
but how do you think that's gonna play
into tap in or maybe even change how
people originally build decks because of
the different you know activations and
the response and stuff like that
keyboardist when I would call Tommy
Nowak Giancarlo so unique told us my you
need to cut off structure though the key
thing about he is anything got a small
okay
they suddenly you know about come see my
you don't know my mother takes coverage
it was a scar and Aikido I keep the
acadec muscle not they're one of the
best car they throw the key gamma-gamma
karoku wrote economic addictive this
coumadin like a door so you're not so no
changes to cemeteries in their major
body is really cool so it looks like
there's gonna be a lot of synergy with
the cards and the characters themselves
so with all of that put together what is
the most important thing
you want everyone to know about tapping
Kazooie lakita iran a character Apatow
joseki a so-called academic our battle
of saratoga was a pipe contract God and
to type in academically to talk over it
was a Muslim and terracotta skyrocket as
a he created a kotahi also based on
slavery mas okay great well thank you
both so much for doing this interview
and for everyone at home if you want to
join in on the ultimate card battle then
make sure you download step into date
it's available on iOS and Android and
we'll see you guys next time